Boris is a key member of the tea was
with the Conservatives you do get very
positive record I'm also got a strong
team why this is because I know it's
quite annoying when they'll go away in a
minute if we finish the public key
workers across the public sector have
made enough sacrifices you have done
your bits the Liberal Democrats believe
it is time to end the era of pay
restraint the low paid well having the
private or public sector have had a
miserable five years finding a bit more
money for them is absolutely the right
thing you trying to do so we and the
others are played by difficulty donkey
that's all right actually when you
jealous that Oliver kinda band's new
status as a pinup well absolutely yes or
no would do you want to be
conservatively that after Cameron's not
there anymore in the dim distant future
obviously it would be wonderful thing to
be thought to be in a position to be
considered for such know that I think it
highly unlikely as I've said many many
times before Boris